who will lead the European Parliament  after Martin Schulz seven candidates are  in the running Malta may be the smallest  country in the EU but it has an  ambitious to-do list for the next six  months streamlining migration fighting  terrorism and restoring trust in the  European Union are just a few items on  its list with rising populism and  soaring unemployment Social Policy is a  looming issue MVP's will sketch out  details for a framework that may be key  for ensuring social security for all  Parliament will discuss emergency aid  for thousands of migrants and refugees  struggling with freezing temperatures in  large parts of Europe